[Music]
John and Kelly let off our couples on
date night the People vs oj nominee
channeling his character Robert Shapiro
well I'm very happy that than fit not
sure here tonight really you're hitting
it I used to make him do it at home
I literally swear to you to do it for an
app engine app where our sweetest couple
of the night had to be Ryan Reynolds and
Blake Lively totally into each other
even when they were apart she's down
there over there yeah
yeah oh they're gonna shine out look at
her she's turning red she's blushing no
every wonder Ryan revealed they brought
their kids with them to LA so we had to
ask can't have more definitely the more
sex but we'll see what happens after
that we're happy to be out we don't get
out very much
also having a kid-free night Justin
Timberlake and Jessica Biel San Silas
you get ready together to help each
other what's the process we kind of like
to match a little bit sometime I always
say if my wife is impressed before I
walk out of the door I'm a winner
before the nights over John Legend and
Chrissy Teigen left Luna at home too so
Chrissy had plenty of time to snapchat
and tweet calling John out for his um
dance moves I just asked if I should
change my name to Stevens good Stevens
so it's very confusing I know but uh Jim
Stevens Teigen is a lot going on and Dax
Shepard and Kristen Bell they didn't hit
the parties after they had game night
instead still dressed in their Golden
Globe duds how long does it take you
guys to get ready for tonight combined
of a couple I took almost three hours
and then combined is three hours and 15
minutes so not fair I sat on a bed
watching Animal Planet
all this all happen